this video is sponsored by photo an
all-in-one online design and photo
editing platform okay so how do you
write a resume that will get you hired
into a cloud role there's already tons
of videos out there that offer free
resume advice but when it comes to
applying specifically to a technical
role in the cloud computing industry
whether that be a solutions architect
role or a cloud engineer role there are
certain things to keep in mind to really
help your resume stand out if you're new
to this channel welcome i am an
associate solutions architect working at
amazon web services and in this video
i'll be mapping out a step-by-step guide
on how you can build a resume that will
help you increase your chances of
landing a job in the cloud make sure you
stay until the end of this video because
i'll be sharing the top resume mistakes
that i've seen people make when applying
to a technical cloud role now speaking
of resumes if you're looking for a
simple resume template photo has over a
thousand designs available ranging from
modern creative and simple styles these
templates come with pre-made layouts and
you can customize the fonts images and
designs of the pages you can see that
these templates provide a skeleton for
you to work with and all you have to do
is fill in the text by writing down your
own details skills and experiences to
get started with building a resume using
photo for free you can click on the link
in the video description below that
directs straight to the photo resume
builder so when it comes to any resume
employers typically look for these three
things first of all does your resume
align with the job requirements
second of all does your resume tell a
coherent story and thirdly is your
resume formatted in a way that's easy to
scan through now let's talk about these
points in more detail and dive into some
actionable steps that you can take
before applying to a technical cloud
role
a recruiter's number one goal when
looking at your resume is to figure out
whether you're a well-suited candidate
for the role the skills and
qualifications required really varies
depending on the job you're applying for
which means you must tailor your resume
based on the job description for example
if you're applying to an aws internship
the level of experience required on your
resume is a lot less compared to if
you're applying for a senior cloud
architect role the first thing to do is
analyze the job description scan for
keywords and highlight the skills you
have next put in the most relevant
experiences onto your resume make sure
you include the company role title and
how long you are there for this is the
resume that i use to apply for an
internship at aws you can see that under
each experience i have two sentences
providing more details on what i did and
what i achieved now the secret here is
to take the keywords from the job
description and integrate it into your
experiences because according to a study
published recently recruiters only spend
an average of 6.25 seconds looking
through your resume so by clearly
showing them that your skills match up
with the job description they're much
more likely to progress you to the
interview stage now a common question i
get asked is what if i don't have any
experience right now and what if the
skills listed don't match up with the
skills that i have there are two
potential reasons for this reason number
one you're applying to a job that is an
entry level and requires specific
industry experience in this case i
recommend looking at more
beginner-friendly roles for example jobs
that have associate graduate or intern
in the title potential reason number two
is that it's too early for you to be
applying to cloud roles although i would
recommend applying to jobs even if
you're at the start of your cloud
learning journey it might be more
worthwhile for you to firstly focus on
building your cloud skills and knowledge
this could be through studying for any
of your certifications or working on
cloud projects
okay so now that your resume aligns with
the job requirements how do you make
sure that this resume is able to tell a
coherent story a resume that tells a
story is much more engaging to the
recruiter and it gives them an
opportunity to connect with you before
the interview actually happens every
story has a beginning middle and end so
don't be afraid to show recruiters where
your journey started and what you're
looking to achieve did you study in
university or did you go straight to the
workplace everyone's situation is
different and it's all about how you're
able to use your unique experiences and
accomplishments to your advantage now
how do you do this firstly order your
experiences in a way that makes sense i
included my education at the top
followed by work experiences and then
university experiences when it comes to
writing dot points about your previous
roles make sure you don't just copy and
paste the job description of what you
did instead you want to be highlighting
your achievements and talk about the
skills you learned for example back then
when i was a teacher at codecamp i used
javascript html and css so i made sure i
included that i was also given an
average rating of 4.9 out of 5 from my
students which shows that i put the time
and effort to teach the content in an
engaging way ideally a resume that tells
a story will help spark the curiosity of
the recruiter to find out more about you
so make sure you spend some time
reflecting on your previous experiences
and thinking about how they all relate
to each other
okay so this is a pretty straightforward
one but also one that people don't
really tend to take very seriously all
you have to do is make sure you keep
your resume to one page make sure that
it's formatted correctly with no typos
and grammatical errors it would also be
helpful for you to get a family member
or friend to help read through your
resume to see if there's any small
errors because sometimes these areas are
pretty harmless but other times for
example if you write the wrong phone
number or email address it makes it
impossible for the recruiter to get back
to you okay so before i share the top
resume mistakes i've seen people make
when applying to a technical cloud role
i wanted to let you know about two
things
a lot of you have been reaching out
asking for one-on-one career guidance so
since the beginning of this year i've
opened up some time in my calendar to do
one-on-one mentoring course where i help
people land a job in the cloud industry
if you're watching this video and want
me to review your resume or provide
career guidance based on your situation
feel free to book in some time with me
second thing i wanted to mention is the
cloud rights community on slack this is
the platform i started last month for my
tech with lucy subscribers and we have
around 600 people in the group studying
for aws certifications together and
helping each other along their cloud
learning journey i'd highly recommend
joining it it's completely free and hope
to see you there
now here are the top three resume
mistakes i've seen the first mistake is
making up job titles and faking your
experience one example of this is if
someone attended a cloud practitioner
boot camp and got their aws cloud
practitioner certification that doesn't
automatically make them an aws cloud
practitioner being an aws cloud
practitioner actually isn't really a
real role so you shouldn't be listing
that under your work experiences you
should still include this certification
onto your resume but make sure you put
it under the skills and certification
section the next mistake is attempting
the one-size-fits-all approach this is
pretty much the opposite of tailoring
your resume when you try to develop a
generic resume to apply to all the jobs
you're interested in you're showing
employees you have experience in general
but that doesn't show them you're
necessarily a good fit for the job that
they're hiring for the final resume
mistake that i've seen people make which
is something i also mentioned earlier is
poor design and formatting i've seen
resumes that are very cluttered and have
no spaces in between the different
sections making sure you have a clean
looking layout is actually so important
because you want the person to scan your
resume to be focusing on your
experiences and not squinting trying to
figure out where to look if you're
looking for a simple resume template
make sure you check out photos free
templates and resume builder as i've
mentioned earlier i have the link to it
in the video description below alright
so this brings us to the end of this
video thank you for watching and please
give this video a like if you got
something out of it if you'd like to see
more videos like this make sure you stay
subscribed to the channel in the
meantime as well feel free to check out
my other videos and i'll see you next
week bye for now
you